and what's up guys good to be here this
is hans kim just hanging out having a
good time
uh i'm living in my van i have
uh
heb parking lot wi-fi right now
just chilling
managing my stream and having a good
time
yesterday i opened for joe rogan i did
that
two nights ago as well so it's been two
days of opening for joe rogan and
tonight i have
goddamn
um
death squad secret show thursday so
it's gonna be a wild wild night a wild
wild week of comedy in the death squad
universe
monday i had
the [ __ ] kill tony i was a guest on
so wait for that to come out in two
weeks
uh and then
tuesday and wednesday i was opening for
uh mr joe rogan
of joe rogan experience podcast fame
and then on today i'm gonna do the
[ __ ] secret show so it's so fun
it's just so much fun
um yeah i mean i opened for joe rogan
and i live in a van you know it's like
it's amazing how much money i'm saving
because
jerogan pays me a lot of money
i mean he pays everyone a lot of money
um but yeah it's so [ __ ] awesome that
i'm saving so much money my asian side
is just loving the savings
i'm saving so much money every day just
living in a van
thanks man the library bit was a bit
that i enjoyed because it juxtaposed
old dad humor with current issues and i
don't think old dads are in a position
to make those jokes right now
um
so
yesterday i met young jamie from
joe rogan experience podcast fame and he
was very nice
very very beautiful man
[Music]
it's cool to hang out in the green room
with him
joe rogan did an hour and 16 minutes on
stage i did 10 minutes and a sweat and
bullets at the end
he was up there for
seven of those almost eight of those
so he's about eight times
more
comfortable and
just more
awesome that i am
which is probably an understatement
uh how long do you plan to stay in the
van
um as long as it takes
i mean maybe if my youtube money comes
in right
then i can move into a real [ __ ]
apartment
um
but
until that happens
i don't know it's just gonna be the van
for me it's the savings are unreal seven
hundred dollars a month goes to whatever
the [ __ ] i want and send it to a
landlord
i already bought this and paid for all
this anyway so i might as well use it
uh how does one start comedy
try saying poo poo and pee pee and
butthole
uh in places where people don't expect
you to say poo poo pee pee butthole
and that is the start of comedy
whenever there's two or more people
gathered saying poo poo pee pee butthole
then there is comedy
that is one way to start comedy
uh how the hell did you even decide on
van life well i looked at our current
economy and how capitalism
uh
necessitates that
the people who own capital have all the
money and i was like
i don't want to be a capitalist because
i don't own anything so why don't i just
live in a van that way i can have all my
time to myself and i don't have to
exchange my labor at an unfair rate
uh and i can
[ __ ] do whatever
i can do whatever i want and i can do
comedy all the time and whatever
yeah uh austin rent is 700
on average i would say you could get
down to 500 if you're willing
john laviolette are you considering
making your youtube channel subscribers
join
uh one word for a little extra so we can
support it
i don't know how to do that i don't know
how to make my subscribers pay me more
money
but uh i can find a way to milk you guys
for all i can
milk you guys for
you better believe i'm gonna do it no
just kidding i don't really i don't i
want my subscriber numbers to be up it's
more of an ego thing than a financial
thing
which uh
is an ego thing for a lot of people hans
who gave the biggest boost of energy
when you heard their name bring you on
stage
i mean
i didn't hear their name when they bring
me on stage it'd be weird if someone was
up there like i'm hans kim and i'm
bringing up my friend
asana mod
um
but i guess you're asking what's the
biggest
person that brought me up right tony
hinchcliffe
uh tony does great intros he's very
measured and composed and very
heartfelt and authentic
i don't need that much money i have
enough money i just need a
steady stream of it so
don't don't send me money unless you can
keep doing it for a long time i don't
need my i have a lot of money in my bank
account i have like fifteen thousand
dollars
which isn't a lot to some people but
it's more money than i've ever had
um the financial thing is just business
baby starting only fans um okay i will
but i don't really know if i want
everyone to see me jerk off
hans you plan to go on the road anytime
perform around the us
um if i get cancelled from kill tony and
joe rogan refuses to
look at me then i will
abscond i will take off i'll be a
vagabond but until then am i happy
hans this is happy hans
this is sad hans
i'm happy and sad i'm both i i'm good
right now it's uh
i am dealing with some
some [ __ ]
that really is not a big deal
but uh yeah i mean it's not a big deal
but it's just a big deal to me i guess
like
i didn't think that i had the best
uh performance
at a show that i recently did and that's
kind of eating away at me i'm not going
to tell you which one because i don't
want you guys to know that i don't have
confidence in one of the shows that i
did but
um
i mean yeah i mean i complain about
capitalists
um
but you know it's like i am in uh
in a capital
country
honestly take joke ideas from the chat
room
uh if it's good
probably not if it's bad
would you make out with red band for
fifteen thousand dollars
a horse
i'm already on a horse i don't need to
get on a horse hey hans who has been
your biggest influence when it comes to
stand-up greetings from mexico
um probably joe rogan that's the reason
why i got started and probably steve
martin and
um
[Music]
others some shoes rogan that help you
out
i'll go to rogan and be like can i get
some shrooms that help me out
i'm kind of low energy right now even
lower energy than i was
even normally but you know that can all
be changed
uh why do you name clout your complete
you know you don't need any of that i'm
just being honest joe organ really
influenced me and that's part of the
reason why i'm doing such a ad hoc
podcast what's your favorite drug my
favorite drug is probably
um
mushrooms or acid
uh
okay i'll start i'll find different ways
to monetize youtube i've been thinking
about doing twitch because i heard on
this podcast uh ludwig and hasan abi and
will have
talked about
uh
how twitch is better because their chat
isn't [ __ ] with as much like youtube's
chat is just like steady stream but in
twitch they just let it come as it goes
but this is a transition period for you
don't worry about not being where you
want to be right now the journey will
take you there i'm not worried about
where i am everyone else is worried
about me living in a van i'm uh i'm fine
with it for now i mean i kind of don't
like being in an heb parking lot right
now
but um
it's fine like inside here i might as
well be inside of a goddamn
home
right now i do as many things in here
that i could do in a home that distract
me from the fact that it's a van because
i can write
um and i can
do other things i'm 32.
um i wish i could bump uglies with kim
congdon um i'd love to live in a van i
used to have a dope livable van
i have a patreon um look for hans kim
patreon so i have one one patron
uh
so that's nice of it
it's uh it's you're so looking at it i
built this van
um
so this is my handiwork i really like it
what is your female comic body count
i've murdered
seven female comics with my comedy by
making them laugh so hard that they had
a period
near lake travis you can park your van
on my place i just don't want to be too
far from the city because i don't want
to have to drive
i don't know where lake travis is i'm
not that familiar with austin
thanks to you thanks man i just went for
four to three patreons yesterday damn
you're doing better than i am
but yeah i mean it's not about the
numbers it's just like fun
have you ever bumped uglies with william
montgomery that's such an obscene
question because i would never
never have sex with that man unless
i got to know him better
and then maybe i might
just people then start speaking in
german
good
idea
oh
i love
my life
i'm not depressed or sad about things at
all
i'm so happy
and i'm getting laid so much
and i'm so rich
and everything i do is [ __ ] awesome
and yoni loves my comedy podcasting
style he says that i'm
such a good energy and he just listens
to me all the time that's what yoni said
at best barbecue he's a big fan of this
podcast so if you like this podcast
you'll love yoni go check out yoni and
his podcast
because he is a big fan of my podcasting
he doesn't think it's low energy at all
have you been related to anyone yet or
has it not come full circle
has it come full circle i have been
related to someone uh my mom and my dad
my two sisters my grandma my grandpa i
got two of those
um so yeah i have been related to
someone
it's just so crazy how much [ __ ] i'm
getting is this live from the van yes is
live from the van in an heb parking lot
how hard is it to write your minute
every week or is it jay easy for you at
this point
um i mean i never know until the day of
but i'm always working on [ __ ] like i uh
i don't work on [ __ ] specifically for
kill tony but if a bit's good enough
i want to do it but like i try not to do
bits that are like too
new because i don't want to burn it
before i've perfected it
perfected it
um
uh so yeah i mean i just uh my jerk
writing process goes as such i think i
like something so funny like how this
guy was like i don't need you to
be political or religiously the same as
me i just want you to be a good hang and
then i was like i hate that sentiment
because
and that is a joke like things that you
normally think
whatever you normally go around thinking
like the best version of that should be
made into a joke and everyone can do it
why is it a trend for korean women to
have surgery on their eyes to make them
wider why is it a trend for american
people to make fun of asians for having
small eyes
i mean if you notice that don't you
think that we notice it when we're
looking at ourselves every day in the
mirror and be like man if only we could
change our physical bodies oh wait we
can we live in 2021. why stay with the
body that you were given when you can
change and improve and make it better
uh most taboo thing you have ever done
most taboo thing i've ever done is
probably trip a girl at church
when i was like six
or five
we uh
it's like
we were like hiding in the pews and then
someone went and got we were such little
[ __ ] when we were kids some guy got
this little girl like come your mom
wants you in the church and then we're
hiding in the piece and when she we
pulled on a little string
and she tripped and a little baby fell
that's probably taboo i wish i hadn't
done that
what's your favorite k-pop group
uh there was a girl named debbie and we
found a dead bee and we called her dead
bee at church so that was pretty taboo
too
um
[Music]
i
do you know the biological reason for
having eyes of that nature
the eyes of this nature comes from
wanting to be very very wise oh i don't
need to see anything also smarter
i can hear everything
the reason for eyes are small is because
i don't know i think it's an epicanthal
fold from the mongols because they live
in the steps and
it's like
it's a layer of skin over your eyeballs
so that your eyeballs don't freeze in
the tundra
and the cold mongol climates
so we have like an extra layer of skin
so if we're both in the [ __ ] alps
right now
guess who's going to be able to see
while your eyeballs are freezing up
me i got these super
uh
comforted
they're [ __ ] plush eyeballs eyelids
they're all [ __ ] wrapped up in a
winter coat
so that's pretty so [ __ ] cool that i
can survive in the mountains with my
tiny little eyes and
all you whites and blacks and mexicans
with your giant eyes just
freezing your eyeballs off while i'm
just looking around and looking at you
with your frozen eyeballs
looking around and dying and
gross
you look like peng dang god damn what
are you selling hans i'm selling my body
and my mind for
for
for
youtube add revenue money
uh what do you eat in a normal day do
you have a microwave in your van i don't
have a microwave but i have a pan and a
pot
and i did dumplings today i ate a little
bit of ribs i got a fridge down here
let me show you guys my refrigerator
that's my fridge right there
that's my fridge
so i refrigerate food and eat it
i have an induction stove
mr winn here's some dating advice
don't
be
so
stupid when you're trying to [ __ ] women
just be smart i'm not high
no one no one accused me of it but i'm
not i just wanted to let you know
what kind of physical exercise regimen
do you follow to look like the peace
that you are well i've worked out for
the first time in a long time yesterday
with my friend gareth at his apartment
we just did some bench press we did some
light pad work with uh boxing gloves on
um dating advice get on kill tony and
kill exactly
i would say um
try to keep it positive okay no one
wants to be talking to a grumpy pants no
one wants to be talking to a depressed
[ __ ]
you got to be happy even if it's not
real just smile and just
try to say the funniest thing
like it's just a game pretend it's like
you're playing a turn-based game and
then the woman talks and then what's
your turn to talk there's a dialogue box
of four things you could say one thing
is super egotistical about how big your
[ __ ] is the second thing is like about
how awesome your career is going the
third is a funny funny thing that's just
so funny and it's like a word play or
like just an observation about socks
or like tacos and that's what girls want
to hear they just want you to turn
reality into a fun time they don't want
to be with someone who's going to turn
reality into another [ __ ] ted talk
who wants to talk to someone like that
have you kissed britney ledesma yet
i don't know why don't you ask brittany
ledesma
be enthusiastic advice coming at
the most unenthused person
you know
i really don't like that you said i'm
not enthusiastic because i am so
enthusiastic like yesterday i ate a cake
and i was like wow cake so delicious i
can't believe it
um
should get an 18 wheeler it's more
racist and or creepy i don't think i
need to be more racist i hate black
people enough
no i love blacks um tis for getting the
balls to attempt an open mic
whoa
thanks for being you
yeah you're welcome
i've been
being me for a while
have you ever been a page boy i don't
know what that means like uh in a
theater like starting showing people to
their seat
uh what is the tips for getting the
balls to attempt an open mic
um here's what i would do
send this for money he said
i don't need
this is for you it's a novelty isn't it
cool that you don't all the other
podcasts are in a [ __ ] home
but in a van it's it's like [ __ ]
awesome
um test for having the balls to attempt
an open mic i would say
just
uh
be like it's time for me to put my ideas
to the test instead of just silently
having it in my head this whole time i
should try to figure out if my ideas are
actually good.com
so test it out
if you do if you have 100 of votes on a
reddit comment it means you're ready for
the next level
know that the van is just temporary
homes before you know it you'll be in
your own sprawling home your talent is
undeniable and the money will come
thanks ride santa cruz bikes i really
appreciate the kind words and the
encouragement and i do know that this
van is only temporary in fact my life is
temporary i have no
belongings or holding on to this world
or whatever oh my god i'm so [ __ ]
um
yeah
you mean 6th street shootings
dude 6th street is not that bad i love
6th street
um the next 6th street blues will
probably
the nasa 63 blues will probably be on
youtube.com in five
days
are you tired yes i'm [ __ ] exhausted
have you seen arcane on netflix no i
have not i don't know what it's about
did you just go through ego death
probably i hope so it's about time
uh tips for a temporary life uh be a
human being that has a 70 to 80 year
lifespan um i mean we're all doing it
we're all living a temporary life roth
ira or 401k roth ira is the new hot
thing 401 k is for like the old boomers
summon your van when you're done okay
eric bravo thanks for
having my retirement plan
and toe
how's your childhood hans any
interesting school experiences or
anything
oh my god
i once peed in my pants in second grade
and my friend tyler cruz found me and
after he found me peed my pants and
didn't tell anyone it was his best
friend
till sixth grade
do you get paid for kill tony every week
that i'll leave to the internet sluice
to figure out
what do you do to help calm nerves
i consume as much [ __ ] as possible if
there's water i'm drinking it if there's
alcohol i'm drinking it if there's
marijuana i'm smoking it if there's a
lozenge i'm chewing on it i'm sucking on
it just whatever
[ __ ] other than your mind you can use
to figure your [ __ ] out do that uh
because you cannot do it on your own
your brain is a trap and it will [ __ ]
you you just have to distract yourself
i have not peed my pants when is joe's
club opening roth iras aren't good
who didn't pee in their pants when they
were young
um
it was second grade so i felt like i was
a little too old for it maybe it was
fourth grade or fifth grade i don't
remember i think it was fourth grade
i peed my pants in fourth grade when
you're nine when it's it's not cool
anymore
when you're like six and you pee your
pants everyone loves that [ __ ] but when
you're nine or ten when you're double
digits and you're peeing your pants
everyone's
everyone thinks that you don't have any
dick control
what is the purpose of life
the purpose of life is to make it better
for those around you
because those around you are the only
thing that will live after you're gone
and they're the only beings that we now
have consciousness
so i'd say make the world better for
people who have consciousness
and then it'll be nice
why not commit misdemeanors
um great idea sort of hip-hop
i would say misdemeanors are the way to
go felonies are a little felonious
why doesn't tony let you make out with
girls on stage anymore
because
it's very very very very sexual and it
just gets people too horny what's the
hardest drug you've done i don't know if
i'm allowed to say this but i've done
methamphetamines
when was your last hug
probably yesterday i hug a lot of people
dude i hugged joe rogan yesterday
it was pretty [ __ ] dope it's one of
the best hugs in the in the business
in comedy a joe rogan hug is worth about
10 crystallia hugs
your opening for joe was hilarious good
[ __ ] thank you full bari barbie
this these are the comments that i need
more of
please everyone just love me because i
need love and i'm just so sad
how do you write jokes what's your
process here's how i write jokes i'm
like what is funny oh you know what's so
funny is like poo poo in a dog's
butthole and then i just say that on
stage
uh how i write jokes is i'm like
wow
i can't believe we have an economic
structure that rewards
only a few people leaves everyone else
to rot and then i write about that until
something funny comes up but usually it
doesn't i write about how people think
that in van life they can just ask me to
do whatever and i have to do it because
i live in a van it's like i live in a
van and i don't get autonomy what do i
gotta do to get hans kim to shout out my
music on kill tony
i'm not gonna do that it's not an ad i'm
trying to be funny
uh just kidding man i'm a huge fan
though i love your stand-up thanks
d-dazzle music
i love you bro
i'm trying to do push-ups and you're
cracking me up
oh thanks man
i
i'll try to not
be such a
push-up cans blocker
will there be episodes of other people
yes okay
yes fine i'll get another person on
maybe they'll be better because then i
won't be so sad all the time
hans you get me through my miserable
work life i thank you for helping me
through the day
you're welcome frank enriquez i'm glad i
could help i don't know what i'm doing
but i'm so glad that it's helping you
um vans off the corner of the street
trademark
um
thoughts on nfts i think nfts is just a
verification system it's like a very
complicated verification system it's
like a password it's like we already
have passwords
i mean is like your system of
verification better what what's the
difference between nfts and captchas
i'm sure i don't know what i'm talking
about but i just don't see how this one
system of verifying whether you have the
code is gonna be the best
i'll do another sixth street um i just
think that uh you know like [ __ ]
nfts are like
like people want it to be a bigger thing
they want it to be more useful than it
is and it's like if they can get more
people on board with it
then they can make money off of it but i
don't know if it's the way to go
um
it's like oh you can verify that you
have this image but it's like the
utility of an image isn't that it's
yours it's like trying to own things
it's like trying to profit off of things
and it's like the good thing about an
image is that you can see it and
appreciate it not that you have like the
only copy of it or something
does dog taste good i don't know does
your cousin's [ __ ] taste good you damn
redneck
it's funny how australia is about at
prison college and jokes and now they
are a prison colony
oh yeah with kovid
if you're sad then i need to look in out
here having a full conversation show off
so does kill tony take care of you what
does a gig like that pay dude i get i'm
loaded right now it's crazy
i'm like sixteen thousand dollars
balling
yeah my glasses are real
they're clear framed
hey
dude i'm so happy right now i'm i'm like
off my tits i need to
do
some
goddamn sudafed right now i'm so [ __ ]
happy
um hello thanks might
yeah i mean i think they're talking
about my redneck comment uh what does
dog taste like
i don't know what
does fried alligator taste like
i have never tried dog
i would especially if it was a bad dog
oh do you get mad when tony calls you
autistic i get autistically mad i'm like
i'm not a distinct how dare you tony
do i smoke weed
does a korean eat dog
yes i smoke weed [ __ ] do you
think you'll ever be famous
uh
i thought i already was
uh you done dmt with joe rogan nope
i haven't i don't think i will i mean
it'd be nice if i could but i don't
think we're there yet i think we're just
still at uh talking in the green room
face
is a sushi really better in austin than
seattle
i don't know
have you ever used the n-word before
yeah i do it whenever it's like funny
when people don't expect it
uh so
a funny thing happened yesterday um
yesterday
i did a mic
yo dave was killed i was i did a mic and
then i went to my van and i slept
outside of the mic in my van and i was
listening to people from my van because
it's an outdoor mic and
mumford davis was killing he's been on
kiltoni before hans what do people not
know about william montgomery william
montgomery is uh
like that off stage and he is like so
[ __ ] nice and he's like
weird
and he doesn't sacrifice any of his
weirdness to be nice and he doesn't
sacrifice any of his niceness to be
weird he is a complete human being
is
pretty [ __ ] awesome
nice haircut thanks i did it myself
only when it comes what's your favorite
dog breed not for consumption
my favorite dog breed would have to be
a german shepherd or something
or a golden retriever
i technically didn't buy anything at
this heb so hopefully they don't come at
me
um or any dog that's like nice like a
labrador or like a mutt that's just like
knows its place and is really good at
what it does and it's like
really athletic
why is tony so mean to red band
because red band is a difficult energy
to handle and
tony is a very unique personality and
they uh have fireworks spark between
them
hans if dog is as good as friend fred
gator it makes sense why you the wet
markets are full of them
um i don't know how bad the korean wet
markets are but
i know the chinese love to eat weird ass
[ __ ]
and they started the coronavirus
that's pretty [ __ ] up dude
stop stop shutting down the world so
that you can eat fried
pangolins
uh what is tony uh hinchcliffe wagon are
the rumors true he is gay
i don't think tony hinchcliffe is gay
tony hinchcliffe is a force to be
reckoned with he is magnetic he's
charismatic he draws all the energy
in the room and he's very very great do
you hang out with nat rogoczewski yeah
he's great he's a nice guy
um i helped him jump his car it didn't
work but it i did help him with that
honda ever perform in new york yes in
fact i lived there for three years
before the pandemic hit i was a new york
rat
i was running around the mics
doing the subways
and it was a great great experience it's
comedy college i loved it and it made me
the sexy little boy that i am today
would you recommend aspiring comedians
to move to austin or is it super
saturated nowhere is super saturated you
can move to texas you can move to l.a
you can move to new york this is our
time we are the ones that have life and
can physically manipulate matter
in this
year of our lord 2021. this is your time
to take charge and control
where
we go as a species and as a planet
and as conscious life do not be afraid
you are one of the few that get to be
alive everyone dead and not yet born is
watching you watching you
hem and ha in [ __ ] biloxi mississippi
wondering if you should make something
of your life while you are already
living it
you
can
change the world
and you should do it because
it's awesome you shouldn't uh be afraid
to use the power to manipulate physical
reality
because you don't get it for long only
70 years so try to use it try to be in a
place where using it has the most impact
and can be magnified
in terms of scale
tony assaulted your people
i honestly don't give a [ __ ] i don't
think that was that offensive and i
think asians are strong enough to handle
that i think that he was doing what he
does to bobby lee all the time and
making a joke about asian people and
trying to transition into a joke
and i don't think that tony hates asian
people
and i don't think that
that's how racism works
but thank you for the advice
i'll be sure to let him know that
you guys are
whatever
any sidewalk such on the van in the
works
maybe
it's just not as good as in a [ __ ]
vulcan theater i'd rather do a set at
the vulcan theater
you have your own manifesto yeah it's
called the whatever
the asian chinkai manifesto
um you know joey diaz
i know of him he used to do comedy in
seattle and there's a bunch of stories
about him
uh
have you done any comedy down here in
canada
up there in canada i've done some comedy
in vancouver bc
i love that place very very beautiful
city for comedy lots of comedians there
um when do you perform tonight at 8 pm
at the vulcan
and then at 9 00 pm at the velveeta room
and then at 11 30 at the roma room why
when do you perform
can i get a kiss mastered ta
uh you sound really manly master machete
sounds like something a dude would think
is a cool word to say
um
can you explain racism for us so here's
how racism works when you see a person
that looks different from you you're
like wow this person is so similar and
yet so different i wonder if there's
differences between him and i that are
biological
and uh and then you're like wow let me
uh
let me try to spot patterns and then you
try to spot patterns and depending on
how good you are at spotting patterns
people call you a racist or not
um but
you know you shouldn't pre-judge people
you should give everyone the benefit of
the doubt and let them woo you
and a lot of racists just want a
shortcut for
uh
judging people because judging people is
hard
um
and instead of using astrology they just
use race they're like oh you're a
sagittarius you are cheap and you love
to hold on to
bicycles and you're
really
uh tall and you love eating shellfish
so yeah
you can say i know a thing or two about
racism i've done it a couple times
myself
holland your youtube feeds keep coming
out now shadowband
who knows
it's probably because my internet's
shitty
oh i should be recording this hopefully
the internet
will figure it out
uh i'm also using heb wi-fi so maybe
that's why what's your favorite video
game of all time starcraft 2. i love the
strategy and i love that it's like
taking for first person shooters to the
next level like if you instead of just
controlling one guy what if you could
control a whole army that's the next
step of modern warfare instead of just
shooting one person you work on strategy
and encirclement and
preparation and economy and logistics so
starcraft is the next level of warfare
is judging the battleground it's like
ender's game is it a hassle keeping the
van organized
sometimes because if there's a little
mess in the van then it becomes a big
mess because it's such a small space but
also on the other hand it's a small
space so it's easier to clean
so you could say it's both
when it's dirty it's really dirty and
when it's clean it's like so easy to
clean so it's both
what's your favorite cuisine my favorite
cuisine
is probably
thai food right now but it changes a lot
sometimes i like mexican food because i
love burritos and the creamy creamy
taste of the refried beans
um
how was your acid trip my acid trip was
acidic
it was not basic you could say that my
acid trip was so fun
uh i love
acid racism is because people from
different places used to concur and be
concord
conquer used to conquer and be conquered
by each other all the time if you saw
someone who was from where you were as
high chance someone was getting wrecked
yeah
yeah it's it's not good what
when you hurt people
any news on when joe's comedy club will
open up yes here's the news right now
everyone listen up joe's comedy club
opens up whenever the [ __ ] he wants to
open it i have no control or say i
haven't even seen it i don't even want
to
broach the subject i'm just so excited
for it that i don't want to [ __ ] it up
for myself
if i get cancelled from joe's club i
will literally
suck on a dude's dick because i'd be so
sad so
don't try to get any secrets out of me
because i'm not trying to [ __ ] myself
like that
nice try i am going to go to joe's club
and whenever it opens up and i'm down
for whatever it is uh
big daddy joe please just do whatever
you want to me in my body
just kidding
he wouldn't want me to say that so
i am just kidding
i i would love to be a part of joe's
club and when it opens up i'm just so
excited about it so i don't i just don't
want to [ __ ] anything up by revealing
things i'm not supposed to
so i'm just not gonna i'm just gonna
talk about how awesome it's gonna be
because that's all i can really say
do you miss kissing the babes on kt
oh you betcha oh i miss it
while holding onto my large [ __ ]
that's my favorite way to miss it do you
ever think ton
oh my god overseas the line when
roasting people or is it all in the
spirit of the roast i mean if he
oversteps the line the crowd doesn't
laugh and then he uh
notices that and comments on it and is a
master of crowd work and so he knows how
to navigate those waters so
uh it's like so crazy that
um
it's even a question because you can
watch him do it online and it's like if
he [ __ ] up then you know it that
happened but he [ __ ] up very very not a
lot
um
is china committing genocide
yes against the uyghur population in
western china
check it out it's called concentration
camps and they put them in there to make
the whole big old china han chinese
which is so
boring why wouldn't you want some
[ __ ] uyghurs in there to [ __ ]
you know give give you guys some normal
eyes
it's just so weird oh my god this stream
is choppy
oh god i hate myself
uh is kissing sugar same as kissing the
normal audience people you ever kiss a
boy
tony could ask for a
i was gonna guess to end the show would
you kiss him again
tony is obviously gay right
is that your background is that your
toilet in the background
this
is my air conditioner it conditions air
um
so
i would not kiss a dude again it's just
people think they want it but then they
get it and then they don't respect you
so
i'm not gonna kiss dudes
is it a hassle came with a van organized
i already did that i see like a real
comedian uh nyc is good but
a meritocracy and there's too much
kissing ass in there
oh if you